I interviewed an ex-employee at Capital
One okay and she told me they run
thousands and thousands of experiments
on humans to figure out what's going to
get them to spend more right and so what
they found is hey instead of it being
cashed back we should make it points cuz
then you go I have 100,000 points I'm
winning oh that's $100 whoops and oh I
can only use it on these certain dates
and these certain flights and I can only
go to Boise in July and so there's all
kinds of stipulations with points shout
out to Boise love you guys big fans
but there's always going to be a trap
and if you think you're winning that's
what they want you to think yeah they
want you to think man I'm really
sticking it to them I'm making so much
money off of American Express and
Discover card and what I found is you
are the best cash back program that
exists